hey everybody what's going on hey your
little name went out and the light in
thing back there how did that happen I
don't know I only just noticed that
happen right now I don't know I just
noticed it where's the uh I don't know I
don't know let me see I got the remote
here oh look at you with your 21st
century remote control
[__] oh my God hi everybody what's going
on uh yeah John gor said wow I never saw
heard of this West Craven movie I had
not either I actually came across this
movie just randomly like on one of those
you know underrated 70s horror lists and
then later I found out that it was
directed by West Craven it's a very
early West Craven film and it was made
for TV um but it was actually pretty
good we had like a good time with it
yeah I kind of question is this made for
TV it kind of felt made it had pauses
like commercials were in there right
right right yeah it was definitely
struct pretty good flick though it was
pretty good I thought I had a I had a
lot of fun with it it's had like a
really stacked cast uh for real I don't
know why it's doing that I don't know
either because it's on two different
light circuits it's on two different
light circuits so but I I can't really
figure out how to do that right now I'll
figure out later well I was going to
say
All Right microphone came unplugged holy
[__] what the [__] is going on oh my God
can everybody okay can everybody hear us
now can everybody everybody hear us now
are we back on
yeah okay they said good yeah now did
you guys get any audio at all in this
show or was it muted the whole time that
must have just come out cuz I didn't
nobody complained about it at first
right yeah but I was just kind of like I
had to track down the wire and see what
where that was and then this little
doohickey like fell out I don't know
when the [__] that happened Jesus well
we're going to have to uh look tuck that
in here underneath well it'll be
sideways then take pressure off of it
there you go yeah because it's gonna
there you go yeah and for a second look
like we lost connection too I don't know
yeah I'm sitting there going uh did our
microphone just break which is cu it was
on it was off and I couldn't figure out
what happened to it okay well that
explained that no ghosts I swear it was
just that little the little [__] fell
out of the side of the computer muted
three minutes in 3 minutes in okay cuz I
was going to say I didn't think it was
off the whole time yeah cuz I thought
like people were answering the questions
and start over we're going to start over
yeah but before we do that like I said I
want to get into our little like
affiliate sponsorship thing uh today
we're going to be talking about
skillshare uh who is the sponsor
affiliate for this show so if you don't
know what skillshare is it's basically a
subscription service you pay like a
small amount every month and you have
access to all of these different online
classes that are about all kinds of
different things particularly like
creative types things like like
marketing productivity figure drawing
portrait painting graphic design video
editing music production anything like
that that if you want to learn how to do
anything like that then you can go on
skillshare and take take classes they
have classes for beginners they have
classes for intermediate they have
classes for experts they have classes
for pretty much everybody thousands and
thousands of them and up until November
30th
20123 uh skill shares having their Black
fridaycyber Monday sale and that means
that you get 50% off a monthly or an
annual subscription it's actually a
really good deal so like I said said if
you there's a link down in the
description box and if you click that
link you can get their uh Black Friday
sale like I said 50% off a monthly or an
annual subscription and you can go take
all the classes that you want to
obviously full disclosure we are an
affiliate so we get a small commission
when you click on that link and
subscribe to
skillit so that out of the way let's
talk about this West Craven movie now
this like I said I heard about this on
some underrated 7s horror list and I
didn't realize it was West Craven until
later like when we first started
watching it and this is available to
free like to watch for free we watch it
on YouTube but um it's on tub also and I
think it's on Plex too so you can watch
it free with commercials now originally
when it first aired on TV it was called
Stranger in our
house however
later on it was actually I think there
was some [__] added into it and then it
was released theatrically not in the US
but in Europe like internationally and
then it was called Summer of fear so I
feel like that's probably the title that
most people know it as but it's under
two different titles now I will also add
that this was based on a novel a ya
novel by Lois Duncan who wrote A lot of
things but she also probably most famous
for writing the also a ya novel on which
the movie I Know What You Did Last
Summer was based so this is the same uh
woman that wrote that book also wrote
this one and it was called Summer of
fear which is why the movie was called
that when it was released otherwise but
yeah so this showed on TV on Halloween
night of
1978 I think it was on
NBC and the actual movie Halloween the
John Carpenter one I think came out four
days before this showed on TV you know
what I mean yeah so this is kind of
crazy so this is West
Craven's I put in the description I put
it's his third is movie The reason I
said that was because his first movie
obviously was Last House on the Left uh
which is great but I love that movie but
you need a shower afterward because it's
very scuzzy second one obviously Hills
Have Eyes oh great flick um and then he
made a porno I don't know if it was a
hardcore porn or a softcore porn and I
can't remember what it's called it's
called like something the fireworks
woman or something like that so I've
have never seen it but I didn't even
know that he made got to track that one
down we got to watch that one now but
then he made this now this was the first
movie that he made after he moved um out
to
California and I guess he took it on
because he wanted to show like his range
you know what I mean that he could do
different types of projects other than
just like exploitation which which is
what he' been known for up to this point
like I said he wasn't a huge hugely
famous at this point but he had made you
know two very popular exploitation
flicks and a porno which like I said I
didn't know anything about until today
but um after this one he made deadly
blessing which I think we reviewed not
too long ago I don't love that movie to
be honest I forgot what that is it was
about like the weird like amishi people
it's a weird ass movie I think we
reviewed it like just a few months ago
got to remember it but um yeah you were
talking about ' 80s yeah this was 80 I
think I think I know what you're talking
about something like I think it was ' 81
yeah um but yeah
so this I don't know I okay so this
movie it did come from a ya novel and
I'm G to say and it was a made for TV
movie so I'm going to say if you're
looking for like Gore or boobs or
anything like that you will find none of
that here and it's not super scary
either it is very ya and I was watching
it I was like this reminds me a lot of
the movie The Craft it's kind of like a
Proto craft I feel like kind and I like
I like witch movies yeah there's only
one witch in this one though yeah one
witch chick who moved her finagled her
way into this other chick's house played
by um fing Linda Blair Linda Blair's
cutest [__] in it she's about 18 or 19
probably at the time I think she's 19
she was 19 when she made this I think
this was right after Exorcist 2 yeah
this was only her third movie too yeah
so you know she's playing a late teen
with her parents and this other chick
moved in and starts scooping up on her
boyfriend and her dad and this chick
starts taking over you she finally
realizes this chick's a witch and uh you
know bad luck it happened before she
realized it but you know that that's
that helped her realize that the chick
was a witch that's kind of where the
where where the fun begins and in the
end she's [__] running around in a
black gown with her hair all [__]
crazy look like a The Witches not L yeah
the witch was and she looked like a goth
chick she looked just
like like in uh fusa bulk when she was
in the uh in the craft so I think it's
where they got the idea it did kind of
remind me of the craft a little bit it's
not like set it a school and there's not
like a whole bunch of witches it's just
one just one yeah they're both cute the
witch had a Linda Blair yeah the witch
is actually played by um what's her name
leap purcel and I knew I had seen her
somewhere I recognized her from [__]
valley girl she was in Valley girl she
was in stir crazy too with um Jean
Wilder and um remember the guy that you
were saying that was in there that was
playing not her boyfriend her boyfriend
was the dude that was like8 feet tall
but he was not really 8 feet tall but
he's super super tall yeah um but the
guy that was playing her brother I can't
remember what her brother's name was in
the movie I was trying to place the guy
that actor he played the teenage
Clark Kent in Superman that's right
that's in the Richard Don Superman yeah
he was in deadly blessing too oh and he
was also in pumpkin head okay yeah so we
might have like recognized him from that
too but I think you probably recognize
him from Superman because you've seen
that Jeff East that guy I kept saying he
was from The Greatest American Hero I'm
like no it's not William cat like I know
who you're talking he's like well no it
was the same guy from Cary I'm like no
that was also William
cat I knew it had something to do with a
superhero he does kind of look like I
knew it was some kind of superhero yeah
that's okay there it was it was Superman
he played Superman young Superman yeah
so the story behind this this thing and
I and I read the I haven't read the
novel but I read the synopsis of the
novel and apparently the movie sticks
pretty close to the novel except for the
end because the end of this um kind of
teases a sequel but of course they never
made that so it ends a lot differently
than
um than the uh movie does and I think
the movie or the or the book rather I
think the book tried to keep it more
ambiguous as to whether that whether she
was a witch or not but the movie they're
like yeah she's a [__] witch and like
everybody figures it out at the end but
I think in the book um you know she
thought she was a witch but I think they
left like plausible deniability so you
weren't really sure if she was a witch
or not or if that girl was just like
jealous and was imagining it also I
think the characters in the book were a
little bit younger because I think the
Linda Blair character in the book was
only 15 yeah you know what I mean
whereas here she's clearly older like
you know what I mean like like a high
school senior yeah she seems to be like
a high school like she's just going to
graduate high school or something like I
said she was 19 Linda Blair was 19 when
she made now Lee purcel who was playing
the cousin who was supposed to be the
same age I believe she was 31 okay she
doesn't look 31 she doesn't look 31
though she's still she could still pass
like for a teenager I thought cuz she
she just gave me like a college student
kind of VI right A girl just just
graduated from high school you College
freshman time yeah yeah yeah and I think
that they were implying that she had
graduated and then she was going to go
off to college at the end of the summer
right so what happens in this so Linda
Blair lives with her parents and her
little brother and she has like a
brother her same age or a little bit
older too we're calling her Linda Blair
because we had you watch this to see
this is a Linda Blair movie She carries
Rachel her character's name is Rachel
I'm just gon to call her Linda Blair She
carries this whole movie it's it's got a
lot of it's got It's got a well-known
cast but this is basically a Linda Blair
movie probably one of the B big highest
quality ones up there with that I that
I've seen aside from Exorcist really I
love made for TV movies yeah this is a
pretty good made for TV movie it would
fly as a if you were to read you could
edit it in a certain way to make it a
future movie but you could tell the
aspect ratio yeah and there's something
about the incidental music and the sound
Night Gallery yeah and and and like it
sounds like every other 70s sitcom Or
Not sitcom just uh
kind of suspense kind of show yeah $6
million doll man or it could even be
[__] love boat for all you know you
know [__] yeah some scary [__] was
going down on The Love Boat they would
have that kind of like I said I just
thought of Night Gallery because it's
like that incidental music like sounds
very similar but you watch this to see
Linda Blair fight witches and the witch
it's uh and there's like kind of a hot
scene at the end you know there's no
nudity in it but you know [__] the
witch is her shit's getting ready to
fall out of the blouse and she's running
around [__] and she's fighting [__]
little Linda Blair and [__] Linda
Blair was bad I know you guys don't know
you know she was [__] dating Rick
James and [__] [__] doing Google
Linda Blair and Rick James there's all
kind of like kind of they're not like
naked photos but there's kind of naughty
photos of them yeah yeah she Linda was
like in bed together Linda may have been
the super freak but she was but has may
have been who he was talking about but
she she definitely he [__] Rick James
definitely said that cold blooded was
written about Lind he said he [__]
loved her said but she broke up with him
after two years she's like yeah I had I
didn't really even realize they went
they went out for that long she was you
know Linda was [__] naughty and then
she did all the damn prison prison
movies and [__] Savage streets and all
that
yeah poor Linda Blair I love Linda Blair
I think she's adorable so it's and she's
adorable in this so uh murder Hornet
said she had big boobs yeah she did well
the thing about it is I mean the thing
about it and like you were even saying
this too like when we first started
watch in the movie you were talking
about like how chubby she was but like
in this movie she's like not I was like
she's not chubby though something they
had her wear she has like a chubby Vibe
but she's not actually chubby she got
chubby cheeks and they had her in
something I thought she was kind of
chubby but then when they show her run
around she she's not yeah she's just
regular SI she does have kind of bigger
boobs but like I said I think that when
they put her in the movies later she was
just kind of I don't know do you want to
use the term voluptuous maybe no she was
she had she had okay she's a little
short she was a short person kind
of curvy for 70s especially movies and
TVs you know but we're not talking Russ
Meyers [__] Cur yeah she wasn't like
bam you know me I'm more into that you
know you should read that I have I have
um Russ Meyers like a biography of R
Meer it's super entertaining
right yeah [__] uh women that size
would be considered tacky I think to put
on T oh we can't put it's kind of sleazy
that's too sleazy that's [__]
terrible you have a whole female I can't
help it I was just bored like that a
whole female body style that that's the
way those women were born they said we
can't put them on TV they're too sley
looking cuz they just [__] nasty cuz
well it's because dude's minds are in
the gutter that's why yeah and the women
are getting
jealous dudes to see that it's like oh
man [__] baby
machine yeah is that really what you
think baby machine John gor said Savage
streets was good too I have a soft spot
for Savage streets actually I don't
think we've ever reviewed that now that
that I think about it yeah murder Horton
said I'm flying to Florida December 1st
going to Tom's house going to go to the
goth club with tennis shoes and a
turtleneck okay yeah we'll see we'll see
how that we'll
see but yeah so cute little Linda Blair
is in this although I have to say her
hairstyle I know it was the style at the
time her hair in this is [__] tragic
it's a tragic hairstyle yeah
um I'm not even level oh my God no PO
worse even
poofier Valerie Bertelli I feel like was
more of a mullet adjacent this is much
more like I don't know this is giving me
like an Afghan dog kind of vibe they
that curly hair very poly it's very very
big curly frizzy kind of hair very
frizzy like very fly away like hair
helmets I was watching like another
review of this movie and they said maybe
that maybe she had that hair so it would
like give her more height cuz she was
yeah
it's it's very yeah and and it's not
just big like I mean this was 1978 and I
know that like' 80s was known for Big
Hair um but this was like this was
egregious even for the time I I'm just
going to say that I don't know how that
[__] happened I'm not really sure either
to be honest and some of the fashion in
this is also kind of horrifying but um
oh and I forgot to mention too that you
know who else is in this in like a very
small role Fran drer yeah that's right
Fran drer is in this hard to recognize
her though she's young she's really
young she's cute in it but I didn't
realize it was FR dresser I'm not sure
if it's her first movie and it's like
she you can still tell like when she
talks you can still tell her cuz she
still has that voice it's not as
exaggerated as it was on the nanny
obviously but she still has that voice
she's the only one in this other podcast
I was watching was talking about it that
they said um that she's like the only
one that looks like she could still pass
like with her hair and her clothes like
you could still look like that now and
nobody would think it was weird but like
everybody else in this movie just looks
so 7s it's just like I don't know what
they were thinking I'm not really sure
either yeah but so yeah so Linda Blair
is this High School I presume she's a
high school student so she lives with
her parents they live out in California
now at the very beginning there's this
movie starts out like with a bang it
starts out with a [__] car chase like
there cars like going all through the
and it's like a POV where they're going
like all through the road and everything
this car goes off the [__] cliff and
blows up and like all cars were
contractually obligated to do in the
1970s when they went off a cliff they
just had to explode so um as they said
on Rift tracks last night the' 70s all
the cars were made of nitroglycerin but
um but because they all just exploded
when they went down a hill so that
happens and then you find out that Linda
Blair's Aunt uncle and housekeeper have
been killed in an accident like out on
the East Coast didn't they say they
lived in the Ozarks or around the Ozarks
somewhere I think that was brought up at
some
point so
um I think it's the mom's sister and
brother-in-law I think it was so they're
all
dead and so their daughter Julia who is
about the same age as Linda Blair's
character Rachel um is presumably left
orphan so when the parents fly out there
to the funeral they actually bring Julia
back with them it's like oh Julia is
going to stay with us over the summer
until she goes off to college like she's
supposed to go to college in Boston or
something like that so she shows up now
when she first get there um I made the
joke initially that she was doing um
Lorraine Warren cosplay because yeah
because she looks very buttoned up um
you know she's like the got the Lacy
tops that's like all the way to the top
and and so you think it's like is she
like a menite or what's going on with
that she looks like some Cel evangelist
chick yeah and then she has like a real
thick like kind of Southern Sound and
accent or like you know kind of a hill
billbilly sounding accent you know what
I mean yeah probably pseudo I notice it
um well it was well it faded as the
movie went on it was really kind of like
the only first which and you find out
why that is later on but yeah so she
seems like real weird and then like
Linda Blair is like talking to her
brother and her boyfriend like what this
weird chick maybe we should like
straighten her out a little bit and get
her up into this century and so they
kind of at some point they like Linda
Blair tries to be friendly toward this
Julia girl it's like hey you can even
live in my room it'll be nice having a
girl my age around but at first like
Julia seems a little bit like a wet mop
you know what I mean like she don't want
to do anything and it's just kind of
like she looks like real square and
she's like no fun and [__] like that but
very quickly um she goes out shopping
with Linda Blair and Fran rusher
characters and she goes off by herself
and without telling anybody where she's
going and she gets a makeover
and she comes back looking considerably
worse than she did before I have to say
because I think that she told she says
that she told the hairdresser to make
her look like Linda Blair so she didn't
go crazy with the frizzy hair but kind
of so it's just like this weird 70s hair
helmet situation and then they put her
in this outfit which I think was like a
hot pink button-up shirt with like a
brown vest over it yeah and like Brown
shorts skirt and like those and those
kind of like um not platform shoes but
those wedge like those wedge sandals and
it looks um I I don't know it looked
really I was just I was like well I
didn't love the Lorraine Warren ship
from before but it looked better than
that Earth Tones were [__] cool in
the I know they were were big end of
that I know they were yeah so then very
slowly um well I don't even know if it's
slowly Julia starts to system a
atically chip away at everything in
Linda Blair's life pretty much so Linda
Blair is um she has a boyfriend named
Mike who's 8 feet tall and she is GNA be
in this horse show where she's kind of
the favorite to win or
whatever and she's going to go to this
dance with her boyfriend and she's
making a dress for it so then in quick
succession the dress that she makes for
the dance she comes out and she's like
man I've pulled this apart like three
times and it looks like ass which it and
it does it looks terrible it just looks
like it's pink and it's kind of like
looks like a bathrobe wrapper it looks
like a bath no it looks like a [__]
bath towel W yeah I thought it was a
towel bath tow it looked like [__] cuz
it's just like hanging off her and she's
like I don't I can't wear this I don't
know what I'm going to do and [__] like
that and so um so she gets upset about
that and then she's supposed to go to
the dance with her boyfriend but then
she mysteriously gets a horrible
horrible case of hives with which and I
mean there's no covering it up with
makeup there's like these big [__]
red boils like all over her face and so
she can't go to the dance
unwisely um they're like well why don't
you let your brother like your boyfriend
Mike take Julia to the dance since you
can't go and I was like that's nice oh
and why don't you let her wear that
dress maybe it'll fit her yeah she takes
over her [__] so she puts the dress
on that looked like horrible on Linda
Blair and she comes out and she's like
Tada and like Julia looks like [__]
fabulous and this [__] like it was made
for her right and Linda Blair is like
[__] my life you know what I mean like
seriously and you you I felt really bad
for her like this whole time because I
was like oh my God that would suck so
hard I saw it Comon though well yeah
yeah this is I'm going to say it's it's
based on a ya novel so everything that
happens in it is like pretty predictable
and it is very much centered around
teenage drama okay like like what it
would feel like if you were a teenage
girl and this other [__] came into your
house and like started systematically
like taking your life away from you you
know what I mean so it's like so she
does that so she's like oh my God this
dress looks so much better on me like
she says passive aggressive [__] but
then like she just straight up gets
aggressive and [__] towards like as
the movie goes on but she's passive
aggressive at first oh I don't know why
like why this fit so much better than me
so she's like that so then she goes to
the dance and then ends up did she [__]
the boyfriend I don't know if they
implied that I well they just fell in
love or whatever yeah so she takes her
boyfriend now the weird thing about it
is that um Linda Blair's brother who is
about the same age as her he's like 19
20 something like that he has the hots
for Julia even though presumably that is
their cousin and nobody thinks that
that's weird like everyone's like oh
it's so cute he has a crush on her I'm
like you related like spoiler alert
they're not really related but they
think they're related they think that's
their cousin
like that's their mom's sister's
daughter right so it's like why do they
not think that's weird that it's first
cousins yeah that the first cousin it's
like everybody be like bro stop
it yeah it's weird that's but like I
didn't even realize that until later I'm
like oh my God they're they're related
they're like I said spoiler alert
they're not really related cuz she turns
out to be not who she's supposed to be
but um but they think they're related
and nobody thinks that's weird so he has
a crush but she's like no I'm gonna take
Linda Blair's boyfriend instead and she
does [__] like her and Mike the
boyfriend are making out in the car
right in front of lind's bedroom window
like they're look she's looking out the
window going that [__] like that
and they're just out there going oh did
you see that did you see us making out
you know what I mean it's I'm like okay
so then it gets even worse
because um you know so Linda Blair's
like hives clear up after the dance
after and after Julia steals her
boyfriend
and then she has to go to this horse
show and compete and she tells Mike off
she's like man [__] off bro I don't even
want to look at your face which I don't
blame her so so she goes to compete her
horse whose name is Sundance who she's
had for like a really long time flips
out and basically like crashes through a
fence and like rolls down a hill I'm
going to say that whoever that stunt
person was that was riding that horse I
hope they're okay because that stunt
looked
really um painful that horse fell right
on that person I don't know if that was
a a a female stunt person or a male
stunt person it was hard to tell
hopefully it was not Linda Blair I don't
think it was Linda Blair I'm sure it was
a stunt person but um yeah so the horse
rolled right over on them whoever it was
so then the horse breaks its leg and has
to be put down so of course Linda Blair
is just inconsolable about this because
that's another thing the horse did not
like Julia like from the beginning cuz
the horse knew what was up yeah that's a
witch yeah I was like no one listens to
the horse nobody listened to the horse
the horse was just like [__] that [__]
she's BL but it's black magic yeah and I
did mention that you don't have to put
horses down when they get L well that's
funny because I I was watching Sinister
Cinema and him and his wife were on
there talking about this movie cuz
they're doing a whole West Craven thing
um a while back and they said the same
thing they're like why would you have to
kill a horse just cuz its leg was broken
you don't do that to any other animal
that's old cow that's that's an old
cowboy thing if if your if your horse
broke a leg while you were on a journey
out in the
field you couldn't fix it there in the
field and you couldn't walk the horse
the 100 miles back to the [__] barn
or the 30 miles to the bar that's kind
of cruel to the horse well yeah so lot
of times they just shoot the horse yeah
and walk
back or walk to the nearest town try to
buy another horse or byy passage back
home but if it happens on the
barn yeah even in 1970 even in 197 and
I'm sure it's better
nowadays like if you had a horse that
when it was like a show horse and you
had money and some place to board it I
mean obviously they can fix them now if
it's a real if it's a if it's a star
athlete horse it'll probably never be
exactly like it was well yeah maybe
that's why they so sometimes they're
like well I don't want to we'll spend
the $20,000 [__] fixing this horse
and then it won't be worth what it is
now would lose money on it put put the
horse down that's a possibility but you
can't fix them that's what I thought
some people would just a lot of people
if they love the horse they going to
have the horse fixed they'll fix the
horse you know then they might put it
out the past or sell it to somebody else
you know and uh although I may be
talking out my ass they might be able to
fix them and they just come back good as
new I mean po uh therapy you know what I
mean post surgery post healing therapy
is is key you might be able to bring a
horse back I had to ask my mom she's
expert on that yeah your mom would know
would know exactly yeah cuz we always
thought cuz and they thought that too
they're like why would you just have to
kill it's like yeah we've always heard
that but it's like that has to be like
an urban leg horrible injuries myself
I've seen [__] photographs of
horrible [__] hoof injuries to horses
where a horse pulled its own hoof off
and there was nothing but just a bone
sticking there and man I saw that
photograph and I was nearly just beside
myself it looks so [__] gross I can't
imagine you could see that [__] bone
of that [__] horse foot and I was
thinking I guess they put that horse
down she goes no no no look at it and
they showed it and it was the after
photo where it all grew back was perfect
oh cuz it's like a fingernail oh that's
good it grows back they did some stuff
and they they did have to do some
surgery stuff but it grew back like a
fingernail the horse was the horse was
normal but it's very painful for the
horse can it be like having your
fingernail worse than your fingernail
being ripped off by the Yeah cuz I mean
that's and that's painful enough but our
fingernails are like little tiny well
mine look at me I I have fake
fingernails on these aren't even my real
fingernails but um but yeah so Sebastian
said I remember this movie now was it a
witch taking over the family Etc yeah
yeah yeah so I also neglected to mention
that this Julia [__] is not only
scoping on Linda Blair's boyfriend but
also on her dad yeah so there's this
whole scene where the mom kind of comes
in the she's like what I hear giggling
or something like that somewhere we're
like uh oh cuz before we've already seen
Julia being like hey I can play chess
with the dad I'm really good at it and
you know bringing out his briefcase and
like kissing him on the cheek and stuff
like that I'm like mm I see where this
is going so so the mom like comes into
the kitchen one night and sees the dad
and Julia who is like half his age at
least and supposedly related to
him um they're like your uncle huh yeah
like they're not related by blood
because like I said I think I think that
but they're related by marriage so it's
still creepy that's still creepy
whichever way you look at it so they're
like in the fridge like giggling and
like feeding each other grapes and stuff
and I'm like oh boy yeah and and then
creep but not illegal actually if she
they were to divorce they could marry
well yeah like I said not related it's
still creepy though just because very
rude yeah I mean it is not supposed to
be [__] your in-laws yeah yeah let's
let's I've known a lot of people that
have done it that's lot of people do
yeah it is like probably more common
than you think it's more common than you
think [__] which is very strange but
I guess that's just people that well
they're around and you see them all the
time so if you're going to if you're
going to cheat or you're going to like
[__] with like oh well this person's
available they're just right there I see
them I heard of chicks fooling around on
their husbands with the husband's
brother that kind of stuff I've heard of
that that kind of stuff happen and the
dude you know and dudes like with with
their wife's sister you know kind of
same kind of thing yeah because like I
said you see them yeah around yeah and
maybe they're thinking too it's like oh
well it's kind of like [__] my spouse
but different yeah you know what I mean
because they're related but it's a
different person like I don't like like
I don't really get why that would be
weird but I mean get why that would be
attractive but cuz the taboo of it
probably I guess you don't have any
brothers
anyway f f don't have any sisters either
no you don't yeah you're you're an only
child yeah that's why I came out this
way Tom is an island oh are you saying
that's kind of why I'm normal because I
have siblings yeah I'm not normal
because fing I was I was an
island unto yourself I've known lots of
only children that were completely fine
and well adjusted but I will say that
certain kind of personality though it
yeah it does it does um and I guess it
depends what kind of relationship you
have with your siblings too yeah like I
have three siblings I have a sister and
two brothers but it's just kind of like
we always got along we're like very very
similar and i' I've heard that other
other people that I know with siblings
are not like that like a lot of times
they're it's a very contentious
relationship but I didn't have that even
that there's a wide Gap like in ages
between all of us so so she's now it's
implied this a TV movie and it's
PG-13 but isn't it I thought it was
implied that the dad and the and Julia
[__] I mean it looked like they were
going to [__] right no they they told
you basically they told you that I mean
it looked like because the mom had to go
on a she was a photographer or something
so she had to go like out on a job so
she had to go out of town and it's like
the second she was gone Julia is like in
the bedroom like trying on the mom's n9s
and [__] like that and he's just like
hey they're telegraphing it to you 70
style yeah yeah they're they're and then
it's like fade into black and I'm just
like yeah they totally [__] and then the
hilarious thing is that at the very end
because I just thought I'd bring this up
at the very end like after the witch
presumably gets killed or whatever even
though that's not what happens which
I'll get into in a minute but everyone's
just like oh everything's back to normal
and the dad is like and I'd be like if I
was the wife I'd be like um did you not
did you forget that you [__] that girl
like what well I don't even remember
what happened happen I was I'm just like
yeah I'm sure so you know what I mean I
was Bewitched the whole time yeah yeah
so um that's your excuse but yeah so
everything just goes back to normal at
the end which I thought was like kind of
hysterical but yeah so so obviously
Linda Blair figures out that this [__]
is a witch but of course nobody believes
her right because she finds [__] in her
room cuz this Witch is like she doesn't
even give a [__] about like hiding all
of her spell stuff like because Linda
Blair finds like a picture of her that
has like breed splotches all over it cuz
you know the hives or whatever and she
finds like a wax figure I guess it's
supposed to be the horse cuz it said it
had horse hair on it yeah so I guess she
was using that to like [__] the horse up
so like the horse would get killed and
so she just leaves it in the room that
they're sharing she Jes to the horse
right so Linda Blair finds all this
stuff and then she's like she's like oh
my God this is a witch and she's doing
all this stuff but like I said of course
nobody believes her now conveniently
there's a wasn't he anthropology
Professor or some [__] like that that
lives across the street or down the
street or something and he happens to
know all about witchcraft so she goes
down there and goes um hey I'm writing a
short story yeah that's it um about
witchcraft or black magic and like she
she wants to know if like people can
control people like that and he's all
into it and he kind of actually believes
her but then she makes the dumbest
decision in the history of decisions I
feel like because she says to Julia
straight up to her face I know what you
are and like I know what you did and you
found this and I'm going to prove it and
I'm going to use like anthropology Prof
whatever his um name was I can't
remember Professor something and she's
like and I'm gonna you know he's going
to help me and then she's like oh he's
going to help you I don't think so baby
and then he has a [__] stroke she
telegraphed it why why did you tell her
I'm like I wouldn't tell that [__]
anything like if I like okay cuz it's a
movie that's what I mean well that well
okay so that's the thing here's if if I
was in this situation like I'm ever
going to be in this situation if I was
in a situation where it's like hey my
long lost cousin like moves in the house
I'm like this [__] is a witch she's
like she steals you away she goes and
[__] my dad she you know whatever um you
know kills my animals so she does this
kind of stuff takes all your clothes
takes all my clothes like and they look
a million times better on her right and
she's just like taking takes all my
friends all this other kind of [__] so
she did that and I suspect that she's
using back black magic I find like
little spells like little pictures of me
with my balls burned out [__] like that
so I find that I am not going right up
to her face and saying [__] I'm on to
you blah blah blah no I'm going to be
like [__] sneaky about it see which
which is exactly what Linda Blair should
have done and see I kind of blame Linda
Blair for getting the professor to have
he didn't die he just had a stroke ice
let me get you some ice yeah he just had
a stroke but um but I was like I kind of
blame that on you Linda Blair because
you shouldn't have said anything you
shouldn't have said that you were on to
her you could have just been like man
you're such a [__] and I don't like you
and blah blah blah you didn't have to
say hey I know you're a witch and you're
doing all this stuff with black magic
because obviously she's going to she's
going to be whatever what are you going
to do about it like because she had
Bewitched everybody in the family like
you know what I mean so they were all
kind of in love with her in a way um
except for the mom the mom they didn't
really go too much into this because
like I said it was mostly focused on
Linda Blair
you know and her struggles I guess um
but she was affecting the other members
of the family as well like she was kind
of being nice to the little brother and
all this other kind of [__] but I feel
like the mom maybe knew something was up
but didn't want
to admit it and the mom like I said saw
she didn't see them [__] but she did
see her husband and Julia like feeding
each other great from the fridge which
might as well be [__] so um she knew
it was up so she kind of knew it was up
but there's a scene toward the end and
this is kind of weird too so the
professor before he has a stroke or
actually no was it after he had the
stroke and then he like woke up for a
second I can't remember but he tells
Linda Blair um because she's like I have
to prove that this she's a witch nobody
believes me and he says witches can't be
photographed and I was like this is the
first time I ever heard of that I
thought that was a vampire thing yeah it
is a vampire thing they just had to have
they just had to have some kind of a
mechanis like a definitive they had to
have kind of thing like where you could
prove it you prove it right that's I've
never heard that I never heard that
either but like I said I kind of maybe
that's an Ozark's folklore kind of thing
that witches can't be photographed so
Linda Blair is trying to get her mom to
take a p hey why don't you take a
picture of Julia I'm sure she'd really
love that BL because she's trying to
prove it to her mom or whatever and
finally she busts out and says to her
mom she's like J she's like Julia's a
witch and all this other and the mom
just like doesn't want to hear it but I
think the mom maybe suspected that she
was right cuz she knew something wasn't
right with that girl but she didn't want
to cuz she thought oh this is my niece
and I don't want to think bad about her
but I think she thought something was up
too but so then it turns out that Julia
was going to kill the mom cuz the mom
was going on the trip she was going to
Santa Fe or some place and um she had
mapped out the trip and like Julia had
like burned this little place on the map
she's like oh she's I'm going to make
her car go off the cliff or whatever
yeah like she did to her parents and um
so like but Linda Blair find finds out
about that and like saves her and
everything but that's the thing this is
kind of how this is different than the
ending of the book because in the book I
think they left it more ambiguous as to
whether Julia was really a witch or not
or if you know um Linda Blair if Rachel
was just imagining all of it in the book
it's obvious like because when Julia
gets mad at the end and she's just like
cuz um Linda Blair like locks her in the
like they have this the big like [__]
cat fight and then she locks her in the
um in her mom's uh what do you call it
dark room and then like Julia like
witches out she gets like [__] big
ass hair and like white contact lenses
and she's like you know what I mean like
she's like that it looks pretty cool
actually she looks she looks like a
million times better yeah she looks hot
yeah she looks hot she looks like a go
chick from the 7s she looks like way
hotter than she the other way she had
the white [__] Hulk contact lenses
that's back when nobody knew what that
was they can do that yeah now you can
buy those things off [__] eBay yeah
for like 10 bucks or 10 bucks yeah techn
I have a bunch of them yeah but um but
yeah but so she actually kind of goes
and like bust the door because I was
just kind of like what she cuz she's
having like a tantrum inside the dark
room I'm like oh you have you're a witch
can't you just bust the door out and I'm
like okay she did she just and then at
the end there's like this big huge
[__] car chase and this [__] which is
kind of hilarious when you think about
it cuz the witches like behind this the
wheel of the car and she's chasing Linda
Blair and Mike in this car cuz they're
trying to go find mom before she goes
off the cliff or whatever and then like
so the witch is driving the car like
like kind of behind them and trying to
run them off the road and [__] like that
it's pretty awesome and she's also
controlling the [__] in their car she
makes it so the brakes don't work and
the windows won't go down and other kind
of [__] so she's like um she has like
pretty good witch powers going to say
but again I think at the end of the book
um you know Linda like basically they
don't say what happens to the witch they
just come back to the house and she's
gone and everyone's like oh well you
know and that's kind of the end but in
the movie you think the witch dies like
that Julia dies like that she goes off
the cliff in a car and the car explodes
obviously because it's 70s and cars just
had to explode so she does that but then
at the end there's like a little thing
where she's turning up at another
family's house going hey I'm the
governance named whatever because you
find out that that [__] wasn't even
their cousin wasn't Julia she was the
housekeeper that was supposedly killed
in the wreck she was the housekeeper
whose name was Sarah and she decided she
was just going to take over Julia's life
which like I said Linda Blair kind of
figured that out too because she Julia
got this letter from somebody and then
like Linda Blair called that person and
the person that she was describing was
not the same like as the as Julia was so
she's like who is this [__] like she's
not my cousin because they hadn't seen
her in a long time so she could pass
herself off as them but um but yeah so I
mean I I don't know like if I hadn't
known this was directed by Wes Craven I
don't know if that necessarily would
have come through because it is very
much like a TV movie this wasn't he did
other TV movies too like somebody
mentioned he did invitation to Hell
which I haven't seen yet but um but I
don't know like for a' 70s TV movie this
was actually pretty fun like I said
there's no boobs there's no Gore
um it's not terribly scary and like I
said it's kind of like all based around
teen drama yeah it's more kind of like a
mystery yeah but like with a like a
witchcraft kind of thing for TV I'm G
I'm gonna I'm gonna uh compare it to
other TV dramas from the
time Salem's lot's better than this it's
a little scarier a lot cooler a lot of
cool [__] happened in Salem's Lot I own
that one on on DVD uh if you've never
seen that that's a good Stephen King
movie that was made for TV I love Sal's
that was Toby Hooper though Toby Hooper
yeah Texas Chainsaw Massacre life force
yeah so that that's pretty good this one
is not quite as good but it's still good
I put it there with kind of like like a
prototype of The
Craft yeah it kind of gave me a similar
vibe to that yeah no by no means it's it
a bad movie it's pretty good I had a
good time with it honestly it's dated
it's from the 70s but if you're watching
a 70s movies you're expecting that it's
a movie of its time it's still cool it's
it's it's uh retro Linda Blair is very
whiny in this though but I really like
her performance though she's like she's
basically like a petulant high school
girl which you know that that tracks
yeah Brady and that's what and that's
what you would be like because her
family seems like they have a lot of
money right like she's got horses and
horse shows so they're obviously like
upper middle class or whatever so she
seems a little she's a likable character
but she does seem like she's kind of
entitled like she's had a lot of stuff
get her but you can understand she's
sympathetic because when this witch
shows up she just starts taking
everything away yeah so it's like so you
can really understand how that would be
because it almost feels like she's being
pushed out of her own family or pushed
out of her own life even like this girl
is like coming in here and like taking
everything away from her life that she
liked and um so so you can sympathize
with her in that regard but she is very
much she is very petulant it's above the
average for TV movies oh yeah
definitely much better than the [__]
from uh 70s TV movie about the [__]
haunted airplane that what was that
flight something or other oh yeah we
watched that not too Longo than that it
a disaster flick about a haunted
airplane I think had Oris borg9 was in
it was he he was in it I think he was in
every movie that one was [__]
incoherent that movie was dab near
incoherent did we review it or did we
just watch it we just watched it went
[__] was
that what is going on
I yeah there were there is something
about 70s TV movies or like failed
Pilots that I really like but some of
them you can tell why it was a failed
pilot even for the 70s like some of them
are just kind of like a lot of 70s T
made for TV
movies were kind of repetitive because
they were
written they were written in a way well
maybe people haven't joined the show on
time yet they you know what I mean they
might have just joined we got recap so
kind of recap but instead of recapping
they just kind of do the same thing
again kind of like the way kind of like
the way uh that uh soap oppers did [__]
yeah you know they' be like d d d after
the break so they're definitely
stretching the movie out right to to to
play 90 minutes or you know what I mean
three seg three television segments
three half hour segments but it has to
have all these commercials in it yeah
it's not solid story this one
is yeah they don't really do too much
recapping I mean it like I said it's
pretty predictable you know pretty much
where it's going to go yeah um but that
doesn't I don't know that didn't really
diminish my enjoyment of it no I think
it's good I thought it was pretty good I
think it's I think it's there with it's
there with Salem's Lot Salem's lot's
above it but it's it's there it's in
that Salem's Lot was creepy as [__]
Salem lot was effective horror movie
yeah Jeffy art said Salem's Lot was
amazing the mark window scene still
makes me yeah a lot of people still talk
about that [__] that's creepy as [__]
that is still creepy that scene let me
in the kid come floating in through the
[__] knocking on the [__] window
oh my God I would [__] a brick if that
[__] happened see somebody floating
outside the [__] wind yeah and like
the I love the look of um of uh Mr Barlo
in that to yeah the [__] vampire um
although in the book he talked he spoke
see but I like it better that he kind of
better in this one he didn't speak
because the guy who played him I don't
think it was really I don't think I'm
not sure that guy was the actual actor
was he yeah yeah yeah he wasn't I saw
him actually I saw him in an episode of
Boris Carlo's Thriller they evidently
rebooted they redid Salem's Lot and it
was more closely more closer to the book
and it evid sucked they made it for TV I
think see that's what just making
something closer to the book that
doesn't always work yeah I said it kind
of sucked looking at you shining
miniseries from
1997 which is exactly like the book
because Stephen King adapted it and it's
and it's about a million times suckier
than the than the Stanley Cooper onein
and I will die on that Hill
um Sebastian says um how about colch I
actually did on my other channel scar
Salon I actually talked about the two
kch movies the nightstalker and the
night Strangler um I eventually I want
to get around to doing the whole series
but I'm still working my way through
Thriller with Boris carof and Night
Gallery so it might be a little while
before I get to that but I did do the
two TV movies though I love those cold
[__] movies actually and um let me see
hold on um Danny Rowling talked about
Bad Ronald yeah I did I think I did a
review of that one too from
1974 that was kind of like that kid that
killed a girl and then his mom hid him
like behind the walls in the house like
so he wouldn't get in trouble and then
she died and then like a new family
moves in and he's like sneaking around
Behind the Walls all the time who was
this what was bad Ronald I've never
heard that was based on a novel too made
for TV uhuh I I didn't see it 1974 yeah
I did a review of it quite quite a while
back I think um or I talked about it
maybe it was on my top five oh I think
it was on my top five from
1974 John gor said isn't burnt offerings
a TV movie no I don't no it wasn't that
was that had a theatrical release did it
not yeah I think it did I'm pretty sure
it did I mean I'm pretty sure that it
did May maybe it was made for TV I don't
think it was though I remember now I got
to look it up they might have released
it and and gave a TV airing of it
because I remember seeing commercials
for it but it may have been the trailer
for it you can you look okay I'll look
but uh if it if that was made for TV it
was you can't tell that movie was
awesome I like burn offering I love burn
offerings yeah I think I even did a
video on my other channel too like
comparing the um the movie and the novel
I'm going to cheat cuz I like the novel
as well I thought it was just a
movie the novel of burnt offerings is
actually pretty close to the book and
that's because the novel was originally
it was written by Robert morasco it's a
1976 film yeah so it doesn't say made
for TV yeah because it yeah it would say
made for TV made for TV yeah but Robert
morasco wrote the novel and he actually
wrote it first as a screenplay and then
he couldn't sell it so he turned it into
a novel and then it subsequently got
turned into a movie um so the only thing
that's different well there's a couple
things different I think I've talked
about this before but um the the novel
has a lot more with the family the raal
family like before they go to the house
like in their little cramped apartment
in Queens or Brooklyn or wherever it is
and um and it kind of goes more into um
Miriam's character and like how uh
upwardly mobile she is I guess like how
she thinks she deserves better in life
so there's a lot more of that and I
think there's a couple things a couple
little details that are different like
toward the like how some of the
characters die and Sh and when they die
and stuff like that but it's other than
that it's pretty much the same um High
Desert says have you seen look what
happened to Rosemary's Baby I did see
that a long time ago but I would have to
like rewatch it it didn't make a huge
impression but I do remember that I saw
it by the way if any of you have ever
read because you know IR 11 who wrote
rosem Murray's baby he also wrote The
Stepford Wives the
novel he wrote a sequel to Rosemary's
Baby and what the [__] was it called Son
of
Rosemary and that
book it's very rare that I don't finish
a book I mean a book really has to
either bore the [__] out of me or just
piss me off so much because normally
I'll try to like finish something
because I like well maybe it'll get
better or maybe it'll redeem itself you
know what I mean it's like a lot of
things could happen Son of Rosemary I
read the whole thing and when I got to
the end that is the only book that made
me so angry that I finished it and then
I just threw it against the wall I've
never done that before ever and I love
IR 11 I've read like he also wrote A
Kiss Before Dying which is also great
but that book it
just CU it basically just like not only
it just kind of [__]
on the the whole the first novel like it
just kind of
retroactively
negated the whole first novel and I was
like why why on Earth would you do that
I don't know what it is with some
[__] novelists you know what I mean
like I said I love IR 11 it's Rosemary's
Baby is great stord wives is great Kiss
Before Dying is great Son of Rosemary
not so much I really did really did not
like that book at all it was good up
until the end and then when I read the
end I was like you've got to be [__]
kidding me I was like that I was like
[__] that it was all just a dream
something like that I mean basically it
wasn't a dream it was spoiler alert it
was a hoax huh no it was no it wasn't a
dream exactly it was a premonition or
they or they tried to imply that it was
a premonition because at the end of Son
of Rosemary it goes all the way back to
before the events of Rosemary's Baby
okay almost like she dreamed the whole
thing before it actually happened but I
was just kind of like God [__] damn
it why that is one of the first things
they teach you in any creative writing
class you can't do that it was all a
dream [__] you just can't do it it's too
cliche and this is kind of this is
pretty much it was all a dream pretty
much but he's like oh no it's a
premonition like she saw all of it
happen it's like I don't I don't care
it's all a dream I I don't like it I
don't like it um yeah oh they're talking
about that movie the car yeah I liked it
yeah we reviewed that we I think we did
a double feature we did the car and race
with the devil we did like Automotive I
do too car the car was good um that was
also a film that wasn't made for TV yeah
I don't think so no now they're talking
about dual now that was um that actually
was that was made for TV but that's a
great that's Steven spiel good I've
never seen it I don't think oh it's
great I've never seen it its entirety
and it's based on a Richard mat novela
which I also have which is also good but
um I think a lot of people don't know
but Steven Spielberg he not only made
duel because that was like the famous
one but he also made another one right
around the same time or maybe a little
bit before or after that was called
something evil and it was kind of like a
haunted house/ demon possession kind of
thing that had that little redheaded kid
from Family Affair in it what was his
name Johnny Whitaker whatever and he was
in it and that's actually not bad like I
did a review of it not too long ago well
it was probably a couple years ago now
but um but I actually really liked it
because I like that kind of haunted
house type of [__] but yeah so if you
haven't seen something evil that's
another Steven Spielberg from from about
the duel era because I know duel gets
all the publicity but I likeed something
evil as well Danny rling said Hider in
the house from 1989 yeah yeah yeah I
remember seeing that Gary Bucy and Mimi
Rogers uh
on the same level as bad Ronald but
scarier an underrated Hidden Gem from
Canada we should probably review that
one of these days I saw it a long time
ago but I haven't seen it since
then um and they're talking about yeah
laurar I remember that the the laurar 7s
end of film jingle all of that kind of
stuff was it it wasn't laurar was it
what was the one that was the at the
beginning of the muppet show that had
like the red green and blue little
Diamond shap type shapes and it had like
a little jingle what the [__] like if
you saw it you know what I was talking
about yeah but cuz I used to love them
up at show so it's just kind of like so
that always just kind of has like weird
Nostalgia for me you know what I
me and Danny rolling also says the
Paranormal Activity films are
legitimately pretty much a witch ghost
genre the thing about it like I saw the
first paranormal activity which um which
I liked it's kind of slow but um but
it's pretty good like it like it's a
good example of how you don't have to
show that much like to make something
scary you know what I mean but I didn't
really cuz I kind of feel like they made
a bunch of sequels of it right and like
kind of expanded the lore out and I kind
of didn't love it when it went in that
direction cuz I kind of like that's why
I don't like a lot of sequels because
they I I feel like by their nature they
always have to expand the lore which
means usually means overe explaining
things which means taking away your
mystery taking away your ambiguity and
so making [__] not as scary you know so
I kind of feel like that's sort of what
they
did I don't know but the first one was
pretty good I don't love it but it's it
was pretty good it was pretty creepy
like the end was pretty
creepy um let's start talking about
Jeffy art said the Remake was awful I
guess talking about the Salems a lot
didn't we
do because remember there was a sequel
called return to Salem's Lot and
remember we reviewed it and it was um
not great oh it was terrible it it
remember that that thing was terrible it
was not great well I was kind of curious
cuz they had it for free and I was just
kind of like oh I don't think I've ever
seen this and we watched it I'm like oh
that's why that's why you never seen
that's why I've never seen it was
terrible because it's
awful but I didn't know about the remake
or anything like that all right so um
are we ready to wrap it up so yeah so if
you're into West Craven and you've
somehow never seen this movie or if you
like 70s TV movies which I like and if
you like Linda Blair and you haven't
seen this one then uh check it out like
I said it's on YouTube for free it's on
tub for free it's on Flex for free you
can see it pretty much everywhere it's
under like I said two titles it's either
called Summer of fear or it's called
Stranger in our house but it's the same
[__] movie from 1978 so yeah um check
it out if you haven't seen it so we are
going to be wrapping it up we will be
back again on Wednesday night and Zach
will be very excited to know well he's
already told me that he's very excited
because Wednesday night the topic that
won in the poll and it's going to be
Thanksgiving Eve but we're going to be
talking about analog Horror in the back
room and Lial spaces so that should be
fun that sounds good yeah so we're going
to be talking about all that kind of
stuff like all those kind of trends that
are going on in horror over the past 10
20 years or so so uh yeah so that's
something I like to talk about so that
should be fun so we will see you guys
again on Wednesday night good night